the family of the man who was shot
wednesday while walking his dogs they
are asking for help now luckily 30 year
old brandon liberty is currently in
stable condition at umc madison
kimbrough is live there tonight with our
story madison
brandon is currently awaiting surgery
here at umc now he was able to verbalize
to police exactly what happened on
wednesday morning when he was approached
by three men who shot him while he was
walking his dogs
the shooting happened around 1 in the
morning in brandon's neighborhood near
pecos and bonanza after being approached
by three men at gunpoint that's when
brandon and his dogs started running and
the suspects pulled the trigger shooting
liberty in his back and his leg his
mother says once he fell they approached
him and held the gun to his head and his
dog's head brandon yelled out he started
to scream for his life he screamed to
help as loud as he could
and at that point from my understanding
they fled police soon arrived and took
brandon to umc at just 30 years old
brandon is an afghan vet who was raising
four kids with his fiancee the family
has set up a gofundme page to help in
any way
according to police the three suspects
are still on the loose now brandon is in
stable condition here at umc coming up
at six we hear from brandon's father
reporting live kimbrough live local now